يعودوا مشروع مطل البجيري لاستقبال زواره
اليوم بعد بعد توقف الدم لعامين من
الاعمال التطويريه ويمتازوا مطل البجيري
باطلالته على مفترق الطرق القديمه للثقافه
والتجاره في حي طريف المسجل في قائمه
اليونسكو للتراث العالمي ويحتضن المطل
ايضا العديد من المطاعم الحائزه على نجمه
ميشلان والتي سيتم افتتاحه فروع بعضها
لاول مره خارج بلدانها الاصلي
من الدرعيه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عن
صفيان هاني مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشرته الرابعه من الرياض بعد عامين يعني
البجيري يعود مره اخرى الافتتاح اليوم كيف
تبدو الصوره ما الذي رصدته ايضا بعد
انتهاء الاعمال التطويريه وخلاص يعني
على مشكله الافتتاح اليوم
نعم نعم نعم نايف نعم نحن نتحدث اليوم انه
هيئه تطوير بوابه الدرعيه خاصه في منتصف
عام 20 20 والتي بدات في اعمال التنفيذ
وحجم استثمارات لادعيه كامله بمبلغ يفوق
الاربعه مليار دولار يعني نتحدث عن هذه
مشاريع تطويليه اليوم بهيه بوابه الدرعيه
تبدا في جني ثمار وايضا اول اصول هذه
الاستثمارات من خلال افتتاح مطل البجيري
وكذلك حي طريف الذي سوف يبدا في استقبال
في الزوار لهاتين المنطقتين ساعه القادمه
سوف تبدا او سوف يبدا الافتتاح الرسمي
بحضور قاده السياحه من دول العالم وكذلك
معالي وزير السياحه السعودي احمد الخطيب
عموما سوف يكون ضيفي معي الاستاذ طلال
ساره وهو رئيس الاستراتيجيه في هيئه بوابه
تطوير ادعيه مرحبا بك استاذ طلال يعني يوم
اول اصول الاستثمارات التي كنا نسمع عنها
سوف تفتح خلال الساعات القادمه حي طريف
ومطر الجيري يعني اليوم هي تطوير بابدعيه
تحتفل بحدث مهم جدا في رحلات التاريخيه
يعني وفي رحلاتها في تطوير مشروع بوابه
الدرعيه بكامل همم تفاصيل بكامل مراحله
همم يعني اليوم حدث مهم جدا همم زي ما
ذكرت نحتفل اليوم باطلاق وافتتاح بطل
البجيري وهو حي البجيري سابقا لكن اليوم
بنسخه الجديده
بالاضافه الى حي الطريفيه همم
طيب طلال بينما ايضا الكاميرا العربيه
التي تتواجد وتلتقط هذه الصور الخاصه من
الكاميرا الاخرى سوف هذا السؤال يعني
يدفعني الى ان اقول ما هي الاستراتيجيه
التي سوف تقومون بها لجذب السياح من
الخارج ام ان اعتمادكم حاليا على السياح
وكذلك المواطنين والمقيمين في الداخل طبعا
بالفعل هناك استراتيجيه زي ما ذكر في
البدايه الاستراتيجيه محدده لسكان الدرعيه
او سكان الرياض وسكان المملكه ومن ثم
المواطنين والمقيمين في دول الخليج
وبالتالي همم الزوار من جميع انحاء العالم
همم اليوم بنشوف انه الافتتاح برده على
هامش الوفد قمه السفر والسياحه هذا اليوم
في دوره 22 لاول مره يقام في المملكه هذه
من احد الاستراتيجيات لانه اليوم عندنا
قائد من جميع انحاء العالم في قطاع السفر
والسياحه برعايه معالي وزير السياحه همم
الاستاذ احمد الخطيب وهو الامين العام
لمجلس اداره هيئه تطوير بوابه الدرعيه
فاليوم هذه احد اهم
انه قاعده سفر وسياحه يبدا يشوفوا الحيه
البجيري وهو اولى افتتاحات الموجوده في
الدرعيه وحي الطريقه التاريخي اا
اه في سؤال اخر السيد رئيس التنفيذي لهيئه
بوابه تطوير الدرعيه سيد جرار يعني تحدث
في خبر صحفي سابقا سوف يكون في 20 30 27
مليار دولار من الناتج المحلي او الناتج
السياحه هنا في الدرعيه سوف يكون دخل
اضافي لميزانيه السعوديه هل هناك ايضا
استراتيجيه لوصول الى هذا الرقم وان ايضا
اكثر من 55 مليون ساعه سنويا سوف يكون هذا
هذا الرقم المحدد بنسبه الاستراتيجيات
ايوه طبعا بالنسبه لعدد السياح تقريبا من
55 مليون صحيح همم من داخل المملكه ومن
خارج المملكه وبخصوص الناتج المحلي صحيح
لانه مشروع هي تطوير بوابه تدريبيه هو
عباره عن مشروع متكامل همم متكامل من
مكاتب من همم سكن من مدارس من اكاديميات
من جامعه من محلات الذئاب في الطبيعي وجود
هذه العناصر كامله مع بعض في المشروع تؤدي
الى زياده في الناتج المحلي وفي تركيز
ايضا على زياده في النادي النادي
هذا وزياده في الناتج المحلي ايضا شكرا لك
استاذ طلال لكن ساره وهو الرئيس
الاستراتيجيه هنا في هيئه تطوير بوابه
الدرعيه اذا بالارقام 55 مليون ساح سنويه
سوف تكون هي الوجهه القادمه والاستراتيجيه
القادمه لهيئه بوابه تطوير الدرعيه في مع
حلول 20 30 وكذلك الناتج المحلي بالنسبه
للسعوديه بمبلغ فوق 27 مليار ريال اذا
ننتظر نتائج هذه الاستراتيجيه مع ايضا
الصور الخاصه في الجهه الاخرى كما
تشاهدونها
الكاميرا
ايضا همم كذلك شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لضيفك
ايضا همم الكريم على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل من الدرعيه انضم الينا مراسل
العربيه